ça marche pas c'est peut-être la
résistance des mortes
elle entoure la neige s'est imbibé de
propylène glycol et s'il n'y a pas de
l'otan température ya pas de vapeur
je connais cette voie 1202 organisme
ressemble est lancé ou alors c'est la
cheminée qui est bouché ah ouais c'est
bon non justement c'est pas très bon il
ya plus de goudron
il ya toujours la nicotine a déjà mis
oui je crois je peux t'offrir un petit
verre avec plaisir alors pour ceux qui
le connaissent pas jamie ou plutôt jamie
guy bernard gourmaud c'est le
présentateur de plein des missions
scientifiques et culturelles à la télé
depuis les années 90 à aujourd'hui
notamment une émission cultissime qui a
bercé tous les gens de ma génération et
plus c'est pas sorcier
le service est pour toi
dans la vie dès qu'ils touchent arnaud
bédat fès brûlures ou bah oui alors
j'aime mieux parce tu le sais mais qui
correspond à 95 % de toute notre culture
scientifique grâce entre autres à
l'émission c'est pas sorcier
alors j'étais pas forcément des contrats
c'est aussi uniquement à cette émission
mais est ce que tu peux répondre à trois
questions de toute la génération s'est
toujours posée bouge pas j'ai réfléchi
vous êtes toujours ami avec fred faux
ouais on est toujours pote évidemment on
s'appelle régulièrement des jeunes
régulièrement ensemble et toujours potes
à ultra aide avec sabine lapd et votent
toutes les équipes ne sais pas ce que
c'est après toutes ces années
est-ce qu'on peut enfin savoir à quoi
ressemble marcel en fait c'est vrai que
tout le monde se pose des questions sur
l'existence de marcel eh bien oui
marx elle existe voilà regarde cette
photo
ah ouais ça quand même un sacré bonhomme
s'est bien fait avoir
pourquoi c'est pas sorcier ça c'est
terminé c'est pas sorcier a duré pendant
19 ans 19 ans c'est long il y avait
prendre le moindre petit peu des routes
une audience et puis c'est pas sorcier a
donné plein d'idées à des jeunes auteurs
plein de talent ont pris le relais sur
le web dans ta carrière tu as fait plein
de choses à se diversifier et a fait
l'émission le monde
quelle aventure tu te considères tu as
même comme une sorte de passeurs de
savoir est-ce que tu était prédestinée à
ça alors pas un milieu scientifique est
en revanche très tôt j'ai l'on dit moins
d'être journaliste pas scientifique et
attention journaliste rock à 12 ans
j'avais déjà envie de faire ce métier
j'ai commencé à faire ce métier en radio
et en presse écrite est ce que je vais
faire c'était décortiquer les mécanismes
par forcément des mécanismes
scientifique
quand je me suis retrouvé un peu par
hasard à bosser sur des sujets
scientifiques
ça me convenait bien pourtant attiré la
plus grande découverte scientifique de
ces dernières années j'étais très
impressionnée par le dernier engin qu'on
a réussi à poser sur mars
insight on a réussi à le poser sur mars
et il est commandé depuis la terre on
est en train de préparer notre futur
voyage aux réglages du nôtre celui des
hommes sur la planète mars vers ya aussi
tout le travail qu'on est en train de
faire aujourd'hui sur les arbres sur la
manière dont on communique les arbres
d'un lézard ou les arbres les arbres
pardon selon tout à quoi ressemblera
l'équipage lorsqu on posera le premier
pied sur mars
c'est un sacré pari c'est quand même un
voyage qui va durer six mois dans un
sens six mois dans l'autre je pense que
ce sera un équipage international
un petit peu ce qui se passe dans la
station spatiale internationale où on a
en permanence
des européens des américains des russes
je te donne ça ce caillou ouais c'est ça
allez bonne soirée
c'est bien je veut bien t'aider voilà
effectivement c'est un caillou salle
alors j'ai appris que tu avais un
astéroïde à ton nom c'est vrai vous
restez le petit bien que j'ai voulu
créer avec ce caillou est ce que tu peux
nous en dire plus en fait c'est un
astronome qui a découvert ces trois
astéroïdes et quand on découvre un
astéroïde et bien
on en informe lignot astronomique
internationale et on propose de les
baptiser est donc cet astronome qui est
bien c'est pas sorcier a proposé à
l'union internationale astronomique de
les baptiser du nom de fred sa ville et
jamais un grand connaisseur de sciences
d'histoire et plus encore tu connais
plein de choses ça c'est impressionnant
ce quart domaine dans lequel était pas
du tout calé en fait y'a plein de
domaines dans lesquels fut pas calais et
je suis même très content très très
content d'être très loin de tout savoir
puisque moi mon plaisir c'est pas de
savoir c'est d'apprendre encore une
question normal qu'on ait encore
beaucoup comme ça tu veux pas qu'on ait
fait un tour d'accord j'ai pas dit ça
nous sommes au musée national d'histoire
naturelle dans la galerie de
paléontologie au milieu des squelettes
de dinosaures avis savais tu que les
avalanches peuvent parfois faire 250
mètres de haut normal les références à
c'est pas sorcier
ça va on fait ça tous les jours
[Musique]
c'est un endroit où j'adore venir parce
qu'on est dans un endroit de
transmission du savoir à quand je parle
de transmission du savoir c'est surtout
la compréhension qui m'intéresse y'en a
été suspendu là c'est un terreau dactyle
c'est pas un oiseau c'est un dinosaure
volant je connais le ptérodactyle par
rapport à power under moi j'ai des
références picturales plutôt prospère
je n'y avais pas pensé à toi lui la
taille du sac à main qu'on peut faire
avec ça
e mammuth qui a donné son nom au
supermarché et également aux pétards
très massif ans mammouths & management
très bien membré ça on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas et donc pour la promettre la la
base
ouais nous ont disparu de la planète
terre à cause de l'ère glaciaire
ça y est la disparition des dinosaures
elle est due à vraisemblablement deux
phénomènes concomitants il ya une
météorite une énorme météorite qui est
tombé sur la terre et cette explosion a
projeté dans l'atmosphère une poussière
phénoménal qui a entouré la planète
pendant plusieurs années plus de
végétation
ils ont rien à bouffer et de fil en
aiguille ils ont disparu donc là c'est
la partie qui est dédié à tous qui est
une baleine tu sais pourquoi on appelle
le thé les tiges d'un parapluie des
baleines à dents parce qu'à l'origine
s'était fabriqué avec les fans ont les
manettes c'est intéressant ça n'est donc
fait des finances et ses espèces de deux
tiges de structure un peu un peu osseuse
qui permettent aux baleines de filtrer
la nourriture non d'essayer qu'on a
pensé que c'était un poisson
c'est l'un des des responsables du
muséum national d'histoire naturelle qui
a
le premier découvert mis en avant que la
baleine était un mammifère comme toi et
moi et non pas un poisson
ça c'est un bras avec les pôles
l'humérus le radius cubitus et là qu'est
ce que s'est passé la main à exactement
regarde si je me mets dans le même sens
que la baleine claque on a exactement la
même
c'est très ressemblants c'est génial
alors si on résume notre histoire une
journée de 24 heures la terre s'est
formée à 0 les dinosaures apparaissent à
23h20 et loeb à 23h59 et 45 secondes
ouais ça va ça vient on dinosaures bon
ça c'est juste pour que tu te tapes la
route
ah ouais t'es sérieux là merci jamie
gérant passé une journée très cool avec
toi j'ai appris des trucs je me suis
bien marré donc voilà c'est juste un au
revoir et à bientôt
eh bien écoutez moi je sais c'est bon on
l'a fait sans la grande
merci pour tout merci norman j'ai passé
une très bonne journée avec toi ça fait
de bienne sourire bon j'imagine que tu
rentres en fusée jami jami
salut normale et merci pour la vidéo
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo avec jamie c'était archicool je
suis désormais encore plus fan de lui
alors petite question qui aimeriez-vous
voir dans une prochaine vidéo de
rencontre répondez dans les commentaires
à bientôt
t'as pas l'impression d'oublier
quelqu'un la norman tu me parles bah
c'est moi la petite voix à chaque fois
c'est moi qu'on oublie c'est toujours
pareil j'en ai maameri là tu votes c'est
pas sorcier ou de toute façon il y en a
toujours que pour jamy et fred
ça commence à bien faire pas du tout
c'est juste que j'ai pas pensé je suis
je suis aussi hyper fan de voix c'est
pas ça le problème mais c'est ça bien
sûr aller ok c'est à bientôt
[Musique]
à
elle va c'est dur de se faire entendre
ici et si vous avez apprécié la vidéo
mettez un petit pouce en l'air et puis
si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à
l'acheminent ch'tis normal c'est le
moment je faire les appuis sont sertis
peut-être la voilà à l'echa hautement